non ma chérie ce n'est pas vrai nous ne
vivons pas comme les autres ce n'est pas
vrai chez où tout est tellement plus
chaleureux mais ce que tu as été chez
nos voisins du dessous as tu remarqué
que chez eux sur la table il y a
toujours tout du pain du vin est
toujours quelque chose d'autre et chez
eux
quel bonheur familial lorsque la mère
dépose sur la table la crème au chocolat
laitance et j'entends encore la voix des
enfants maintenant sa santé des enfants
est cette jeune maman comme elle est
toujours joyeuse avec ses dessous sig et
tan tan tan tan tan tan
chez eux tout est différent mènent leur
grand mère quelle jeunesse tu t'es
jamais demandé pourquoi la nôtre un côté
faisait figure d'ancêtre mais tout
simplement parce que leur grand mère a
eu vie sans angoisse car un est entier
qui tient avec l ciment je voudrais bien
sable mais le fait est que c'est pas
avec nos grands mères à nous que nous
pourrions tous ensemble sans danger
crunch et devant la télé une même leur
chien leur chien est plus souple
il faut le voir descendre des escaliers
comme un lion descente son arme au
ralenti
les fellahs et l'un parce qu'ils ont
trouvé la nourriture pour chien qui lui
convient mais tu crois que je le vois
pas que d'autres chiens nous et khâgneux
qui se casse la gueule dans les
escaliers mais il ya plus grave
chéri il y à plus grave tu te plains
qu'au bureau malgré mes diplômes je
n'arrive pas à me faire une place mais
je sais pourquoi un collègue de bureau
m'a fait des confidences tous les matins
lui après avoir bu sans chocolat shoot
il coûte nu dans les prés quant à cheval
fou a vu partir au bureau - et puis je
sais aussi pourquoi au bureau je suis
rejetée je le sais malgré tous ses
efforts ma chemise sans être sale n'est
pas aussi blanche que celle de mes
collègues de bureau
et et je ne parle pas de blessure plus
secrètes
mon haleine par exemple mais tu crois
que j'aurais pas envie moi aussi comme
tous les chefs de service de m'approcher
de la secrétaire en faisant au moins à
moins que ce ne soit mon odeur auteurs
il faut voir le vide autour de moi quand
j'ai terminé ma partie de tennis etc air
de dégoût dans mon dos alors alors tu te
plat que je fume trop mais sais-tu
qu'avec une seule bouffée de sapporo en
feeds je retrouve le calme des grands
espaces
pourquoi veux tu que je n'ai pas envie
au milieu des embouteillages de me
retrouver un cow boy solitaire au milieu
de la prairie devant son feu de camp
avec sur le feu une cafetière en émail
bleu
et au loin les coyotes qui font entendre
leurs cris tout ça grâce à chérie chéri
et si recommencer tout à zéro
et si ce soir tous les deux on essayait
de nettoyer la cuisine mais avec vous
cette fois ci tu n'as pas envie d'une
petite tornade blanche